par jour nous avons dépassé les
vingt-cinq mille malades par jour en
moyenne c'est à dire plus de mille
malades diagnostiqués dans notre pays
chaque heure du jour et de la nuit
ces chiffres il double vous l'avez dit
monsieur le premier ministre tous les
quinze jours malgré tous les efforts et
ainsi sans mesures nouvelles
là où c'est nécessaire pour freiner
l'épidémie
il y aurait dans quinze jours plus de
cinquante mille malades diagnostiqués
chaque jour pire encore c'est en
particulier chez les personnes âgées
au delà de 65 ans que la dynamique
épidémique semble désormais la plus
forte depuis quelques jours cela même
ces personnes
au delà de 65 ans qui même s'ils peuvent
être en très bonne santé par ailleurs
présente le plus grand risque de faire
des formes graves
l'impact sanitaire c'est à dire ses
formes graves celles qui nécessitent un
recours à l'hôpital
voire dans les cas les plus graves un
recours à la réanimation
cet impact sanitaire il est réel il est
palpable et au delà des chiffres qui
peuvent s'égrainer au quotidien ce sont
les appels des médecins et des soignants
qui reprennent ce que nous avons connu
au printemps dernier mais appel de ces
médecins qui au quotidien se bat pour
sauver des vies à l'hôpital et qui nous
disent faire face à une vague de malades
graves qui arrivent par les services d
urgence par le samu et qui remplissent
les hôpitaux et les services de
réanimation
il y avait hier près de 2000 malades
hospitalisés et plus de 250 patients
admis en réanimation en région auvergne
rhône-alpes au 15 septembre il y avait
80 8 malades en réanimation au 2 octobre
il y avait 149 malades en réanimation
hier il y avait 3 160 malades en
réanimation
quand je dis 109 sans mesures nouvelles
la situation s'aggraverait la même
manière et c'est à dire que les mesures
qui ont été prises comme la limitation
des grands rassemblements la fermeture
des bars la limitation des
rassemblements y compris dans la sphère
privée à 6 personnes maximum ou encore
le couvre-feu partout où il a été mis en
place
est ce à dire que ces mesures seraient
inefficaces la réponse est non et vous
l'avez dit monsieur le premier ministre
il est trop tôt pour pouvoir tirer
les conclusions et les enseignements de
l'impact de ces mesures pour freiner
l'épidémie
un rappel lorsque le confinement
généralisée a été mis en place dans
notre pays les courbes ont commencé à
s'infléchir à partir de 15 à 18 jours
c'est le temps qui est nécessaire pour
véritablement mesurer l'impact des
mesures que nous prenons et
effectivement en début de semaine
prochaine
nous espérons des premiers signes un
frémissement de l'incidence à l'échelle
du pays sur la courbe qui apparaît vous
pouvez vous poser la question pourquoi
est ce que cette courbe qui augmentait
avait commencé à s'infléchir avant de
repartir très fort c'est un phénomène
que nous ne conduise avons constaté en
france mais également dans les pays
voisins je pense à la belgique en
grande-bretagne en espagne mais
désormais aussi en allemagne et l'italie
des chercheurs se penchent sur la
question peut-être est-ce lié à la vague
de froid qui a frappé l'europe le grand
refroidissement qui est arrivé à cette
période là qui fait que l'incidence est
reparti de plus belle en tout cas ce qu
on peut aussi retenir de cette couronne
c'est qu'à un moment les mesures de
gestion les mesures pour freiner la
diffusion du virus avait commencé à
porter leurs fruits c'est exactement ce
que nous attendons des mesures qui ont
été mises en place de façon
proportionnée sur le territoire national
pour les prochains jours et les
prochaines semaines et vous l'avez dit
ce n'est pas de la prédiction c'est
hélas une évidence une certitude le
nombre de formes graves le nombre
d'hospitalisations le nombre
d'admissions en réanimation et le nombre
de décès va forcément augmenter dans les
semaines qui vont venir parce que ce
rêve n'est que le reflet des malades qui
sont diagnostiqués actuellement un
malade qui se contaminent va développer
des symptômes 4 à 5 jours après quand
ils développent des symptômes en général
et les formes graves apparaissent entre
8 10 voire 15 jours après la
contamination ainsi quand vous avez une
incidence comme celle que nous avons en
france ou en europe chez des personnes
dites fragiles vulnérables de fait de
leur âge eh bien on sait hélas qu'un
certain nombre d'entre elles iront
nécessairement à l'hôpital est en
réanimation
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que de
soignants et nos médecins sont en alerte
permanente en ville comme à l'hôpital
ils sont en alerte permanente pour
d'abord faire de la place à l'hôpital
au delà même des réanimations il y a un
besoin de lits hospitaliers et des
mesures sont mises en place je vais vous
en citer une qui est en cours de mise en
place dans la région ile de france
le directeur général de l'agencé
régionale de santé demande par exemple
aux établissements privés qui ont des
services de rééducation qui ne sont pas
forcément occupé de pouvoir y transférer
des malades qui vont à l'hôpital dans
les services de médecine qui ne sont pas
atteints du coc vide de manière à
libérer de la place dans les services de
médecine dans les hôpitaux et dans les
cliniques pour pouvoir y admettre des
malades atteints du coc vite car de la
place est aussi préparer les
réanimations vous savez nous l'avons dit
et répété nous avons les équipements de
protection qui sont nécessaires nous
avons des médicaments de réanimation
avec un stock national permettant de
soigner davantage encore de malades si
c'était nécessaire que pendant la
première vague
je n'ai jamais caché que l'enjeu majeur
était celui des ressources humaines
identifier des soignants des médecins
des infirmières des aides soignants
capable à nouveau comme ils l'ont fait
avec leur courage extraordinaire de
venir et des épaules et renforcer les
équipes
lorsque cela devient nécessaire le
premier vous aviez annoncé la semaine
dernière des mesures pour majorer les
heures supplémentaires pour les aides
soignants les infirmières des
compensations au cas où des congés ne
pourrait pas être pris nous avons
également dans le cadre du budget de la
sécurité sociale financée
tout ce qui relèverait de l'hébergement
de l'alimentation des transports à
l'instar de ce que nous avons réalisé
pendant la première vague de soignants
sont certes des héros qui prennent soin
de nous mais c'est aussi à nous de
prendre soin d'eux c'est également la
préparation de la réanimation ce qu'on
appelle la déprogrammation
quand on veut augmenter les lidd réa il
faut fermer d'autres lits pour les
transformer en lit de réanimation
vous le savez nous n'avons pas souhaité
des programmes et l'ensemble des soins
sur tout le territoire national
contrairement à ce qui avait été fait au
printemps dernier notamment du fait que
la progression est moins exponentielle
le site be rue circule un peu moins vite
et donc cela nous permet d'avoir un peu
plus de délai pour pouvoir fonctionner
de façon pratique chaque hôpital
chaque région chaque département est
doté d'un protocole sanitaire lui
permettant de savoir comment agir dès
lors que la pression sanitaires
un exemple dans la région auvergne
rhône-alpes l'ensemble des soins de
chirurgie programmée en dehors de la
chirurgie qu'on appelle ambulatoire ou
de la chirurgie cancérologique
l'ensemble de la chirurgie programmée
dans le secteur public et dans le
secteur privé ont été retardés suspendu
pour une durée d'au moins deux semaines
pour laisser de la place déjà dans cette
région auvergne rhône-alpes des
transferts de malades graves ont lieu au
sein de la région entre deux hôpitaux
quand un hôpital n'a plus suffisamment
de places est alors s'enclenche la
dynamique de création de montée du
nombre de lits de réanimation pour
pouvoir accueillir de nouveaux malades
quelques chiffres nous avions dans notre
pays historiquement 5100 place de
réanimation avec respirateur et équipe
personnelle
nous sommes montés à 5800 lit dans la
durée à la faveur de l'été avec des
efforts conséquents qui ont été réalisés
par l'ensemble des hôpitaux + 15 % de
places de réanimation nous sommes
capables de monter à 7700 lit dans un
délai de moins de quinze jours sans
forcément des programmes et beaucoup de
soin et sans forcément rappelait
beaucoup de personnel mais au prix quand
même d'un effort d'organisation
important et s'il devenait nécessaire
d'augmenter davantage encore nos
capacités d'accueil en réanimation
sachez qu'au 15 avril dernier il y avait
eu dix mille 700 lits de réanimation
armée mobilisée pour accueillir des
malades
ce qui ne veut pas dire 10700 malades
ducobu puisque quoi que nous fassions
nous aurons besoin de lits de
réanimation pour des malades qui
viennent pour d'autres motifs en moyenne
au moins 3000 lits sont occupés au
quotidien par des gens qui sont en réhab
d'autres motifs quand on parle de la
préparation du système sanitaire
on parle du système sanitaire dans son
ensemble et c'est un système qui a su
s'adapter et qui s'est encore s'adapter
même sous une forte pression épidémique
par exemple nous sommes passés en deux
semaines d'un virgule un million de
tests réalisés par semaine à 1,6 million
de tests réalisés au cours des sept
derniers jours
et le tout sans augmenter les délais
puisque 90% désormais des résultats des
tests réalisés sont donnés dans les 48
heures
un autre exemple de la mobilisation
chaque jour les agences régionales de
santé le personnel les équipes qui
travaillent au sein des agences mais
aussi au sein de l'assurance maladie et
les médecins en ville sont capables
d'appeler 90000 français c'est à dire le
nombre de gens qui sont contaminés est
diagnostiquée pour le grenat virus ainsi
que les cas contacts c'est un effort
sans précédent dans l'histoire
sanitaires de notre pays enfin et vous
me l'avez déjà entendu dire plus d'une
fois mais je le répète quand on parle de
système sanitaire
on parle des femmes c'est des hommes qui
sont mobilisés au quotidien les
infirmières les aides soignants les
laborantins les biologistes les médecins
les brancardiers les ambulanciers ce
sont eux qui prennent soin de nous et
quand je dis que nous devons prendre
soin d'eux jeudi que le gouvernement
faisait sa part mais c'est aussi à
chacun de nous qu'il revient comme
citoyens de faire preuve de solidarité
de faire attention dans notre quotidien
de ne pas prendre de risque de ne pas
exposer les personnes autour de nous au
risque de contamination
c'est ainsi que chacune et chacun
d'entre nous français citoyens pouvons
aussi accompagner nos soignants dans la
lutte qui a débuté et qui sera longue
contre cette épidémie merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre je veux à mon tour
remercié une fois encore tous les
soignants les équipes techniques et les
laborantins les personnels
administratifs et finalement l'ensemble
de cette chaîne de santé de la médecine
de ville aux établissements de soins qui
sont en première ligne depuis mars
dernier et qui sentent à nouveau mis à
rude épreuve
jeudi également ma gratitude aux
collectivités territoriales impliqués
dans la mise en oeuvre des mesures de
restriction mais également dans les
indispensables actions de communication
et de prévention notamment vis-à-vis des
publics vulnérables ou fragiles mais au
delà de notre capacité à prévenir à
dépister à soigner au lait au delà des
mesures administratives que nous
déployons je veux un
6t solennellement sur le fait que nous
avons besoin de l'implication de tous on
ne cesse de le dire et de le répéter
mais je le fais encore car c'est une
conviction profonde
la clé de cette lutte contre l'épidémie
est plus que jamais entre les mains de
chacune et de chacun de nous nous
détenons tous à notre niveau
une partie de la solution elle est
connue porter le masque se laver très
régulièrement les mains ou utiliser du
gène tousser ou éternuer dans son coude
ou dans un mouchoir utiliser des
mouchoirs à usage unique elle est jetée
salué sans se serrer la main et éviter
les embrassades respecter une distance
d'un mètre
aérer les lieux dans lesquels vous vivez
et travaillez et enfin plus que jamais
réduire ces interactions sociales
c'est un sujet de responsabilité et de
solidarité collective
c'est aussi un enjeu de protection pour
tous tant qu'on n'est pas touché on se
croit intouchable
pourtant ce virus frappe tout le monde
il concerne tout le monde jeunes et
moins jeunes en ville comme à la
campagne avec certes des formes plus ou
moins graves mais sans que nul ne puisse
considérer à l'abri y compris les jeunes
j'en appelle donc encore et encore à la
solidarité nationale et à une
mobilisation sans faille car si nous ne
réussissons pas collectivement à juguler
l'épidémie
nous ferons face à une situation
dramatique et nous devrons envisager des
mesures beaucoup plus dures
il est encore temps de l'éviter mais il
ne nous reste plus beaucoup de temps
je voudrais donner la parole au
professeur étienne gaillat directeur
médical de crise à l'hôpital
lariboisière qui va nous rappeler que
tous les types de profils peuvent
développer des formes y compris grave de
la maladie
pêcheurs merci beaucoup monsieur le
premier ministre
et merci de me donner l'opportunité
effectivement de vous présenter quelques
éléments de la réalité de ce qu'on vit
dans les hôpitaux et en particulier aux
hôpitaux d'ile-de-france dans lesquels
je travaille ce que on observe depuis
quelques semaines c'est effectivement
une augmentation continue du taux
d'incidence du virus dans toutes les
classes d'âgés ce qu'on a observé c'est
une augmentation qui a commencé dans les
classes d'âge les plus jeunes des
patients de moins de 30 ans et puis puis
un peu plus tard des patients de moins
de 40 ans et on voit aujourd'hui une
augmentation qui s'infléchit encore
fortement chez les patients cette fois
plus fragiles parce que plus âgés donc
ça nous rappelle effectivement que un
des moyens efficaces et dont on espère
que notamment le couvre-feu portera ses
fruits c'est de limiter la diffusion et
la circulation est aujourd'hui à 15
heures mais d'assas et de limiter nos
interactions pour éviter de se
transmettre le virus on observe parmi
les patients qu'on a à prendre en charge
quotidiennement des formes de
contamination à l'intérieur de la
cellule familiale à l'intérieur de
couple on a eu à prendre en charge en
particulier dans la première vague et on
espère ne pas la voir aujourd'hui des
couples y compris des couples en
réanimation
atteint de lakovic 19 donc ça c'est une
réalité
la deuxième réalité c'est on a eu
l'impression d'entendre que le virus
dans sa forme d'aujourd'hui était moins
grave et éventuellement moins virulent
est ce qu'on observe c'est pas tout à
fait ça malheureusement
on observe deux faits c'est que les
patients qui sont admis dans le service
de réanimation
quand on regarde à peu près la
distribution de l'âge et qu'on la
compare depuis cet été par rapport au
premier pic épidémique est bien cette
distribution de l'âge allait en fait
strictement similaires encore une fois
parmi les patients les plus graves à
savoir que 50 % des patients admis en
réanimation ont moins de 60 ans et quand
on s'intéresse encore à des patients
plus jeunes on a effectivement entre 15
et 20 % de patients de moins de 40 ans
en réanimation traître est factuellement
ya dans le
quel travail qu'est l'hôpital
lariboisière sur les 32 lits de
réanimation qui sont ouverts 15 patients
atteints de kobe de 19
trois d'entre eux ont moins de 40 ans et
ont fait des formes graves
ce qu'on a observé pendant les premières
semaines de l'été c'était et des
patients qui présentaient notamment
moins de besoins de ventilation
artificielle
ce qui était évidemment un signal très
positif malheureusement on observe
maintenant depuis quelques semaines une
remontée de ses besoins de soins très
lourd de réanimation qui fait dire que
la virulence du virus est la même et
qu'elle touche toutes les couches de la
population
un message important moi ce que
j'aimerais porter au nom de la
communauté soignante et singulièrement
celle de réanimation c'est d'essayer de
contredire un peu l'idée que la solution
face à cette remontée épidémique et à
cette deuxième vague
ce serait d'augmenter les lits de
réanimation ce qui sous-entendrait que
venir en réanimation c'est pas grand
chose quand on vient en réanimation
malheureusement ce qu'on observe c'est
15 20 % de patients qui n'en sortiront
pas parce qu'ils y mourront et que parmi
ceux qui sortiront de réanimation il ya
encore des patients qui continuent de
mourir dans l'année qui suit et beaucoup
d'entre elles observent avec lakovic 19
comme on l'observé avec les autres
pathologies de réanimation sortent avec
des séquelles lourdes dont ils mettront
du temps à se remettre
donc vraiment le message c'est par
d'augmenter le nombre de lits de
réanimation c'est de tout faire pour
éviter l'admission réanimation et donc
éviter la circulation du virus et les
contaminations
un des moyens c'est effectivement encore
une fois la distanciation
on l'a beaucoup dit on a observé comme
étant efficace et puis tout ce qui est
le tracking des patients c'est à dire
être capable de repérer les patients qui
ceux qui sont contact d'un cas positifs
afin d'éviter que même à et contaminer
d'autres patients c'est aussi une
réalité qu'on partage il ya des patients
qui n'ont pas de symptômes et qui sont
pourtant contagieux et c'est cela
probablement qu'il faut identifier le
plus tôt possible pour éviter
plus de destinations je remercie
monsieur merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
monsieur le professeur face à
l'accélération d'épidémie qui vient
d'être rappelé nous devons mobiliser
tous les outils les nouvelles
technologies constitue un de ses outils
utiles pour retracer les chaînes de
contamination et ce tout
particulièrement lorsque la circulation
du virus est élevé et nous y sommes
le gouvernement lance aujourd'hui la
nouvelle la nouvelle application tous
antilles qu'aux vide
elle est disponible au téléchargement
dès aujourd'hui et je vous invite à tous
la télécharger comme je lé fais moi même
je possède la parole à cédric au le
secrétaire d'état en charge du dossier
pour qu'il vous présente les nouvelles
fonctionnalités de l'application
merci monsieur le premier ministre les
mesures qui ont été annoncées
aujourd'hui sont difficiles et olivier
ferrand le miz de la santé l'a dit elle
pourrait l'être encore plus à l'avenir
mais cela n'est pas inéluctable
nous ne sommes pas condamnés à une
politique de stop and go dont nous
savons à quel point elle est pénible
pour nos concitoyens est dévastatrice
pour notre économie
pour cela et monsieur le premier
ministre l'a rappelé nous avons besoin
d'être chacun d'entre nous acteurs de la
lutte contre le virus
c'est bien sûr le port du masque ce sont
bien sûr les réflexes de distanciation
physique c'est bien sûr la réduction de
nos interactions sociales mais c'est
aussi l'utilisation de tous les outils
qui peuvent nous aider à contrôler un
virus qui va durer tout en continuant à
vivre et notamment les outils numériques
ces outils numériques doivent permettre
à chacun d'être acteur des trois piliers
de la stratégie mise en place pour
réduire durablement la circulation du
virus est de participer à notre
résilience et à notre résistance
collective
testez alertés et protéger ce que nous
voulons faire avec ces outils numériques
c'est rendre chaque français réellement
acteurs de l'ensemble de la chaîne de
lutte contre le virus
c'est d'abord tester et je veux rappeler
ici l'existence et l'utilité du site
dépistage qu'ovide point gouv.fr je
répète dépistage peu vide point gouv.fr
qui permet à chacun de trouver
facilement un laboratoire près de chez
soi et d'être informé des temps
d'attentes
il ne faut pas renoncer à se faire
tester par ce que l'on pense qu'on ne
sait pas où aller ou que c'est trop long
cet outil développé avec les équipes du
ministère de la santé vous facilitera la
vie si vous devez vous faire tester et
surtout vous permet en remontant vos
informations sur les temps d'attentes de
partager une information précieuse pour
tous c'est aussi alerter et monsieur le
premier ministre vient de le dire
pour gagner du temps sur le virus nous
avons lancé aujourd'hui l'application
tous sentis qu'ovide mise à jour de
l'application stop que l'idh il faut au
sujet de l'application stop qu'ovide
être extrêmement clair oui
l'application n'a pas été suffisamment
télécharger pour être un outil vraiment
utile dans la lutte contre le quran à
virus et s'il faut en prendre la
responsabilité nous l'apprenons
entièrement moi le premier mais cette
adoption insuffisante est aussi
malheureusement collectivement une
opportunité manquée personne ne se
réjouit de devoir fermer les restaurants
les bars ou encore les salles de concert
et de cinéma personne ne se réjouit de
devoir limiter ces interactions sociales
mais pour éviter cela et pour éviter
cela à l'avenir
nous avons besoin de tous sentis comme
id le conseil scientifique
dans son avis rendu aujourd'hui a été
extrêmement clairs sur ce point la
diffusion massive des applications du
même type à l'étranger au royaume uni en
allemagne au canada confirme ce que les
études épidémiologiques les chercheurs
et les soignants ont toujours dit et
demander si nous sommes suffisamment à
télécharger à activer cette application
cet outil peut être extrêmement utiles
dans la lutte contre l'épidémie
suffisamment cela veut dire que nous
devons être plusieurs millions à le
faire les britanniques et les allemands
sont entre 15 et 20 millions à l'avoir
fait il n'y a pas de raison qu'il n'en
soit pas de même en france
un rappel peut-être sur ce qu'est tout
senti que vides c'est très simplement un
geste barrière supplémentaire afin de
lutter contre l'épidémie et sa
propagation
tous senti que vides fonctionne de
manière simple si vous avez croisé le
chemin d'une personne contaminée dans un
bar dans un restaurant dans un cinéma
dans un lieu recevant du public et que
vous aviez tous les deux l'application
alors vous pourrez être prévenues dès
que la personne en question recevra le
résultat de son test ce qui vous
permettra premièrement d'être avertis et
de vous isoler ce qui vous évitera de
contaminer de nouvelles personnes
surtout si vous êtes à symptomatique
tout senti que vides nous permet de
gagner du temps d'utiliser le message
reçu dans l'application pour avoir accès
à la file prioritaire de test des cas
contacts comme tout les compères sont
identifiés comme qu'à contacter par
l'assurance maladie
tous antico vide c'est un geste simple
que nous faisons souvent télécharger une
application mobile l'activer et la
garder ouverte
mais à l'image d'un vaccin est jolie dit
ce geste n'est utile que si nous sommes
très nombreux à le faire
c'est pourquoi je veux m'adresser
directement à tous les français à toutes
les françaises et tous les français
nous avons besoin de vous nous avons
besoin de tous
nous avons besoin de chacun toutes les
garanties ont été prises la cnil la
commission nationale informatique et
libertés a auditées en profondeur et
valider l'application son code source
est ouvert et public et permet à chacun
de vérifier ce que je viens de dire tout
senti que vide n'est pas un outil pour
le gouvernement il est un outil
collectif très largement soutenu par la
comité communauté médicale qui doit nous
permettre de garder les lieux de vie
ouvert qui doit vous permettre de vivre
le plus normalement possible tout en
vous protégeant cette application c'est
la vôtre
téléchargez la réactiver la dès que vous
vous rendez dans un lieu recevant du
public
depuis stop qu'ovide la boucle de
l'application a évolué elle continuera à
le faire
bien sûr elle conserve sa fonction d'
historique des contacts avec les mêmes
garanties pour la vie privée mais avec
olivier ferrand nous l'avons fait
évoluer pour en faire un vrai outil
individuel d'information et de lutte
contre l'épidémie
c'est pourquoi elle intègre dans la
version mise en ligne aujourd'hui des
éléments d'information quotidiens tels
que le nombre de personnes testées
positives chaque jour le
aude ainsi dos d'incidence le fameux air
ou encore le taux d'occupation des lits
de réanimation par les malades qu'ovide
ces éléments donnés dans un premier
temps sur une base nationale seront
adaptés à la ville de chacun dans les
jours qui viennent d'après l'application
présente également ses chiffres
d'adoption nombre d'enregistrements
nombre de cas déclarés dans
l'application et nombre de cas notifiés
ceci dans une logique de transparence et
de mobilisation elle diffusera également
plusieurs fois par semaine des éléments
d'information ou d'actualité sur la
connaissance et la lutte contre le virus
elle intègre enfin un lien vers la carte
de dépistage qu'ovide point gouv.fr qui
recense je le rappelle l'ensemble des
laboratoires ou se faire tester cette
nouvelle application nous incarnons par
un nouveau nom tout senti qu vide et un
nouveau logo que vous avez découvert
derrière moi ces premières
fonctionnalités seront enrichis toutes
les deux semaines de nouvelles
fonctionnalités parmi celles ci je pense
notamment à l'intégration de
l'attestation de sortie ou encore à une
alternative aux caïds rappelle dans les
restaurants tout cela car l'épidémie est
appelée à durer
je veux à cet égard insisté sur cette
notion de temps n'attendons pas avec ce
redémarrage de grand soir de tous sentis
co-lead nous avons besoin dans la durée
que plusieurs millions de français
téléchargent l'application
c'est pourquoi nous voulons encore une
fois dans la durée faire de tout senti
que vides un couteau si ce n'est un
couteau suisse numérique pour faciliter
la vie quotidienne avec l'épidémie
protéger enfin les français sont
mobilisés dans la lutte contre
l'épidémie il souhaite adopter les bons
gestes pour se protéger et protéger les
autres mais ils ont souvent besoin de
conseils personnalisés
le numérique est un formidable levier
pour le faire dans un contexte on le
sait où l'information foisonnent et
évolue sans cesse
c'est dans cet esprit et avec l'ensemble
de la communauté médicale qui a été
développé mes conseils qu'ovide point fr
je répète mes conseils que vides point
fr ce site vous permet renseignant
quelques questions d'avoir des conseils
personnalisés et si vous êtes touchés
par le virus
il vous permet de suivre dans le temps
vos symptômes et de prendre les bonnes
décisions
ensemble ces trois outils forme à tout
pour faire du numérique
l'outil de chacun et de tous dans la
lutte contre le virus
merci beaucoup monsieur le secrétaire
d'état de ces informations importantes
mesdames et messieurs l'instauration du
couvre-feu et son extension à de
nouveaux territoires a et aura des
conséquences économiques lourdes pour de
nombreux secteurs professionnels
pour y répondre les mesures de soutien
économiques annoncées la semaine
dernière seront étendues à l'ensemble
des départements basculant sur le régime
du couvre-feu le renforcement du fonds
de solidarité
les exonérations de cotisations sociales
le prolongement des prêts garantis ainsi
que des dispositifs d'activité partielle
nous continuons à travailler en lien
avec les fédérations et les
représentants des différents secteurs
concernés pour continuer à améliorer nos
dispositifs mieux prendre en compte les
loyers payés par ces entreprises ou
encore encourager davantage la médiation
entre locataires et bailleurs avancer
sur la question des congés payés et
proposer un nouveau régime d'assurance
pour les entreprises en cas de
catastrophe sanitaire à tous ces
secteurs économiques particulièrement
impacté par les mesures de restriction
que nous sommes tenus de prendre
hôtellerie bar restauration
événementielle sport culture et d'autres
encore a tous je veux dire que le
gouvernement comprends leur désarroi et
parfois leur sentiment d'injustice alors
qu'ils ne demandent qu'à travailler et à
vivre de leur travail
ces mesures ne sont en aucun cas des
sanctions contre eux elles sont des
mesures de prévention destinée à limiter
la propagation du virus est d'ailleurs
tous les autres pays prennent des
mesures comparables
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
solidarité nationale doit comme nous le
faisons depuis le début de cette crise
se déployer en leur direction
au nom de quoi n'indemnise aurions nous
pas
des secteurs que pour des justes raisons
d'intérêt général sanitaires nous
empêcherons de vivre normalement
cela a un coût bien sûr mais les laisser
tomber
aurait un coût moral humain mais aussi
financier bien plus lourd encore
s'agissant en particulier du secteur de
la culture
nous avons reçu ce matin avec la
ministre de la culture les représentants
du cinéma et du spectacle vivant
ils nous ont fait part de leur grande
difficulté à maintenir leur activité en
raison du couvre-feu
nous avons travaillé ensemble à des
dispositifs de soutien spécifique pour
faire en sorte que les salles de cinéma
ne ferme pas partout en france que les
salles de spectacle puisse rester
ouverte
le plus possible pour préserver l'accès
à la culture est essentielle en cette
période de crise comme nous faisons tout
pour maintenir l'accès à l'éducation
pour nos enfants
la ministre va vous présenter les
mesures que le gouvernement a décidé
d'engager en faveur du secteur culturel
voici donc madame roselyne bachelot
oui le premier ministre le ministre de
la santé le professeur gaïa l'ont
rappelé la situation sanitaire est grave
et la mesure de couvre feu qui a été
annoncé par le président de la
république doit nous aider à affronter
collectivement cette deuxième vague à
stopper la propagation du virus et à
mieux protéger chacune et chacun d'entre
nous vous l'avez dit monsieur le premier
ministre cette mesure de santé publique
et de protection a un impact très fort
sur le monde de la culture à nouveau
particulièrement atteint en effet
l'essentiel du spectacle vivant et du
cinéma se déroule en soirée dès mercredi
soir
j'ai échangé avec les professionnels du
spectacle vivant et du cinéma comme je
le fais avec l'ensemble du secteur
culturel depuis ma prise de fonction
individuellement et collectivement
j'ai également eu à coeur d'évoquer la
situation avec plusieurs élus locaux
concernés et j'ai souhaité réunir mardi
prochain les associations d'élus dans le
cadre du conseil national des
territoires pour la culture
vraiment je tiens à saluer les efforts
qui ont été faits par les professionnels
de la culture extrêmement engagée à
maintenir le lien avec le public et qui
sont en train de s'adapter de trouver
des solutions dans ce contexte nouveau
l'etat sera à leurs côtés pour surmonter
cette crise et les accompagner dans
leurs efforts d'adaptation et
d'innovation
ce soutien est extrêmement important et
ça nécessite est partagé par l'ensemble
des français
chacun a besoin il nous avons besoin de
culture est peut-être encore plus durant
cette crise qui a fact affecter notre
capacité à nous rassembler et les
mesures que je vais évoquer sont
essentiels elles vont permettre de
préserver l'accès de tous à notre
culture
bien entendu je souhaite d'abord
confirmé que le renforcement des mesures
transversales que vous avez décrite
monsieur le premier ministre et qui ont
été annoncées par bruno le maire jeudi
dernier toutes ces mesures vont
s'appliquer à l'ensemble du secteur
culturel et notamment au spectacle
vivant et au cinéma
cela veut concrètement dire que la
culture est éligible au fonds de
solidarité aux exonérations de charges
sociales à l'activité partielle
lorsqu'elle est nécessaire ou prêts
garantis par l'état ainsi qu'à toutes
les mesures d'accompagnement pour ne pas
que le secteur culturel s'effondre le
gouvernement a décidé de prendre
également des mesures spécifiques
complémentaires
s'agissant du spectacle vivant ce sont
85 millions d'euros dès dettes qui vont
être débloqués
en effet dans les territoires concernés
le couvre-feu a de lourdes conséquences
sur le maintien de l'activité
les structures adapte les horaires mais
évidemment elle ne rencontre pas
forcément leur public
la fréquentation et donc leurs
ressources vont diminuer notre objectif
c'est à la fois de sauvegarder les
programmations et les salles en
permettant de jouer même à jauge
extrêmement réduite pour le spectacle
vivant musicale le fonds de sauvegarde
et le fonds de compensation seront dotés
de 55 millions d'euros complémentaires
dont 3 millions destiné particulièrement
aux auteurs les dispositifs mis en place
seront confiées au centre national de la
musique et bénéficieront à l'ensemble
des acteurs du secteur privé ou
subventionnées nous allons par ailleurs
proposer au parlement de prolonger
d'exonération de la taxe sur les
spectacles au premier semestre 2021 pour
alléger les charges des entreprises du
secteur pour les autres champs du
spectacle vivant notamment le théâtre y
compris les auteurs une enveloppe
complémentaire de 20 millions d'euros
sera mis en oeuvre pour accompagner le
secteur privé comme fut comme le secteur
subventionné
y compris les auteurs enfin pour ne
laisser personne de côté début septembre
le ministère de la culture
mis en place un fonds d'urgence
spécifiques est temporaire de solidarité
aux artistes et techniciens du spectacle
qui n'entrait dans aucun autre
dispositif
nous allons l'abonder le doublé pour
atteindre 10 millions d'euros deuxième
secteur de la culture particulièrement
touché le cinéma avec le couvre-feu les
deux séances du soir de 20h et de 22h ne
peuvent plus tenir
or ces deux séances représente la moitié
du chiffre d'affaires des salles notre
objectif est de faire en sorte que les
cinémas ne ferme pas que le public
puisse continuer à aller voir des films
pour cela il faut que les sorties de
films soit maintenue sur l'ensemble du
territoire
malgré les risques économiques
importants pris par les distributeurs
au total les mesures qui vont venir en
soutien de l'activité du secteur
cinématographique représente 30 millions
d'euros pour cela nous mettons en place
quatre mesures la création d'un
complément de prix sur chaque billet en
zone de couvre feu pris en charge par
l'état est reversée aux distributeurs
pour alléger les risques qu'ils vont
prendre un bonus renforcée du soutien
automatiques générés par les
distributeurs
pendant les six semaines de couvre feu
nous doublerons également le barème
normal du soutien automatique pour les
producteurs sur cette même période
jusqu'à 1,5 million d'entrées et enfin
le fonds de compensation des pertes des
exploitants sera parallèlement ray
abondé afin de tenir compte de la perte
supplémentaire de chiffre d'affaires que
représente le couvre feu pour les salles
de cinéma ce sont donc au total 115
millions d'euros qui vont être injectés
pour soutenir le spectacle vivant et la
culture
c'est un nouvel effort exceptionnel qui
vient s'ajouter à toutes les mesures que
nous prenons depuis le début de la
pandémie
je veux vraiment remercier du fond du
coeur les professionnels pour leur
engagement de tout faire pour continuer
à ouvrir dans les conditions sanitaires
les plus sûres
et je remercie évidemment nos
concitoyens qui on le voit depuis le
début de la semaine
vol continuer à aller voir des artistes
sur scène et aller voir des films et je
veux leur dire que le président de la
république le premier ministre et le
gouvernement sont à leurs côtés pour que
notre culture ne s'arrête pas merci
beaucoup
madame la ministre mes chers concitoyens
la situation est difficile mais l'état
est prêt et l'ensemble du gouvernement
est mobilisé avec l'état toutes les
collectivités publiques et les services
publics les contraintes que nous devons
collectivement nous imposer sont
importantes c'est jamais parfaitement
conscience cette crise sanitaire est
appelée à durer sans doute plusieurs
mois encore mais si nous faisons
ensemble les efforts nécessaires en
respectant les règles communes ou
individuels pour réduire la circulation
du virus
nous pourrons alors alléger les
contraintes qui pèsent sur nos vies
quotidiennes
je vous remercie et je me tiens à votre
disposition ainsi que les ministres
présents pour répondre à vos questions
bonjour adrien bec pour europe 1
monsieur le ministre vous avez indiquée
quant au cas où l'épidémie n'arrivait
pas être jugulée vous devriez mettre en
place des mesures plus dures mais nous
ne disposerons pas de beaucoup de temps
de combien de temps estimé vous pouvoir
encore disposer est en fête avons nous
encore du temps pour tf1 essayé j'ai
plusieurs questions vous avez dit que le
mois devra l'être difficile est-ce que
vous avez des projections qui vous
permettent de savoir si on va atteindre
un pic de l'épidémie est ce et quand
autre question sur l'application tout
senti qu vide
vous venez d'en faire la promotion mais
il y aura-t-il d'autres campagnes pour
la rendre plus populaire auprès des
français
et enfin je voulais parler des vacances
de noël je sais que vous avez peu de
visibilité mais est ce que les français
doivent s'attendre à ce que leurs
vacances de noël soit perturbée
notamment les rassemblements familiaux
on va prendre encore une ou deux
questions et plus on va reprendre ce
premier jet bonjour monsieur le premier
ministre madame la ministre monsieur le
ministre flamand tardif pour ses news
canal + je vais rejoindre la question de
mon collègue qui a été posée
précédemment concernant justement ces
mesures plus dures qui pourraient être
prises dans les prochaines semaines
puisque ce mois de novembre sera
compliqué éprouvant même pour reprendre
vos propos est-ce que le couvre-feu est
un prêt confinement est ce qu'on se
dirige vers le confinement et seconde
question concernant la stratégie du
gouvernement selon les données santé
publique france en semaine
quarante-et-une 27,1 % des nouveaux cas
était connu comme étant précédemment des
cas contacts pour reprendre les propos
du ministre des solidarités de la santé
ce n'est plus nous qui traquent oms le
virus c'est le virus qui nous traquent
souhaitez vous évoluez dans la stratégie
de dépistage est par exemple avoir une
stratégie qui dit à la japonaise
rétrospective en tentant d'analyser
comment une personne positive a été
contaminée et non plus quels sont ces
cas contacts merci beaucoup
une dernière question pour un premier
achat et ans répond oui frédéric haziza
radio j aurait complété la question
précédente dont vous avez évoqué la
possibilité d'envisager des mesures plus
dures et c'est à dire qu'en cas
d'aggravation de la situation
le couvre-feu pour évoluer vers un
couvre-feu à la guyane c'est à dire un
couvre-feu de
17 heures à 5 heures du matin le
lendemain et le week-end du samedi 13
heures au lundi 5 heures
bon on va répondre à ce premier jet de
questions je demande au ministre de la
santé de s'approcher du pupitre parce
qu'évidemment beaucoup concernent une
précision préalable j'ai dit et je
confirme que le mois de novembre sera du
site parce que nous savons déjà que
quels que soient les faits que nous
espérons positif des mesures de couvre
feu l'impact l'impact des contaminations
actuelle sur la montée d hospitalisation
en réanimation se fera sentir fortement
on en est sûr maintenant au mois de
novembre
d'où les difficultés que je pressentais
donc s'agissant de durcissement des
mesures d'abord le ministre va compléter
mon propos elles vont évidemment
dépendre de l'évolution des données
épidémiologiques à partir de la semaine
prochaine
de l'intensité de cette évolution est
donc nous nous tenons prêts comme
toujours envisagé plusieurs scénarii et
plusieurs catégories de mesures monsieur
le ministre ce 1er mai ce premier
ministre pour éclairer la réponse à la
question qui a été posée qui est
finalement on a presque tous intégré
l'idée du couvre-feu manifestement
aujourd'hui
et qu'est-ce qui pourrait intervenir
pour la suite comme a dit parfaitement
monsieur le premier ministre d'abord si
on pouvait se passer d'autres mesures je
pense que tout le monde s'en porterait
bien à commencer par les malades
eux-mêmes les hôpitaux la population les
soignants devraient dire que les mesures
que nous prenons ont un impact
moi je ne voudrais pas qu'on sombre dans
le défaitisme par avance et qu'on
considère que le couvre feu n'aurait pas
vocation à fonctionner d'abord parce
qu'il a fonctionné il a fonctionné en
guyane alors les horaires ont évolué du
couvre-feu en guyane blackburn est un
territoire particulier avec un
ensoleillement qui était particulier des
pratiques qui sont en termes de travail
d'horaires de vie qui peuvent être
particulière surtout à la saison les
cours de laquelle le couvre feu s'est
appliqué mais c'est vrai que les
horaires ont pu évoluer s'est passé de
21 heures à 19 heures et puis ensuite à
17 heures le couvre-feu il a fonctionné
dans d'autres endroits à l'étranger si
on regarde par exemple espagne l'espagne
a mis en place un couvre-feu un
madrilène qui concernait un certain
nombre de quartiers du centre de madrid
alors dans le cas de l'épidémie
madrilènes s'étaient très focalisée très
concentré sur certains quartiers dont
ils ont tapé entre guillemets tout cas
ils ont agi fort sur les quartiers les
plus à risque et ils ont réussi à
obtenir des résultats notamment par
l'entremise du couvre-feu
d'autres pays ont mis en place des
mesures qui s'apparente à un couvre-feu
l'angleterre a déjà annoncé pour une
durée de six mois
des clôtures précoce des bars et des
restaurants sur tout le pays
et puis enfin il ya d'autres pays qui
ont fait d'autres choix
l'allemagne fait d'autres choix même si
j'ai entendu la mère de berlin a parlé
de la possibilité de mesures proche d'un
confinement si la situation persistait
l'italie a mis en place des mesures qui
s'apparente au couvre-feu en lombardie
et puis d'autres pays sont allées encore
beaucoup plus loin
je pense à l'irlande et au pays de
galles qui ont prononcé un confinement
généralisée d'une durée de deux semaines
qui pourraient être étendus plus tard
plus loin donc on sait comment vous dire
les deux situations ne sont pas
forcément comparable
les unes aux autres l'une à l'autre par
contre évidemment qu'on s'enrichit les
uns les autres et on discute cette
semaine j'ai eu plusieurs de mes
homologues mon homologue allemand
anglais espagnol italien au téléphone
pour discuter avec eux alors tu as mis
ça en place dans tel endroit
au bout de combien de temps ce qui est
des résultats les communautés
scientifiques se parlent au niveau
stratégique aussi au niveau technique
tout le monde se parlent échangent on
continue d'apprendre de ce virus
c'est un virus qu'on ne connaissait pas
il ya quelques mois il ya un peu moins
d'un an on ne connaissait pas
et regardez la sortie de l'été vous
aviez encore un certain nombre de gens
qu'ils aient maintenant virus a disparu
où il a changé en réalité on continue
d'apprendre donc nous espérons que le
couvre-feu sera une mesure de nature à
permettre de freiner l'épidémie de
préserver nos hôpitaux et de sauver des
milliers de vies si jamais la situation
ne devait pas être celle ci alors c'est
un conseil de défense et de sécurité
nationale qui se réunit sous l'égide du
premier ministre et du président de la
république des propositions sont faites
on rapportait dans le cadre de ce
conseil sur la base des propositions qui
elle-même émane de la communauté
scientifique et ensuite les décisions
sont prises quelles qu'elles soient sur
des talents le dépistage à la japonaise
mais j'ai vu ça j'ai lu ça aussi mais je
n'ignorais pas je m'étais aussi
entretenu avec mon homologue japonais
figurez vous pour discuter de cette
stratégie
j'ai discuté tout à l'heure avec le
professeur de médecine qui vous a
présenté la situation dans son service
et je vais poser une question que je
pose souvent que j'ai posée hier à des
médecins stéphanois ou est-ce que les
gens qui sont en réanimation se sont
contaminés ou est-ce qui se sont
contaminées mais la réponse n'est pas
simple
ces spas professeurs la réponse allait
pas ça même quand vous avez un
échantillon de 15 20 malades et que vous
prenez le temps de décortiquer avec eux
où ils ont pu être contaminées
vous dis parfois ça peut être un mariage
parce que vraisemblablement la personne
à fréquenter un mariage donc ça va être
là parfois ces dix personnes qui vivent
dans un deux pièces
dont une personne était malade donc on
se dit que c'est ici mais en réalité il
est extrêmement difficile d'autant que
vous avez plus de la moitié des gens qui
sont asymptomatiques
donc vous avez pu être contaminées à un
moment vous ignorez vous même totalement
par quelqu'un qui lui-même ignorait
qu'il est un contaminant
c'est pas une question de faillite ou de
déroute ou deux c'est des systèmes de
traçage ou de la communauté scientifique
et médicale
henri d2 c'est très dur et y compris au
japon quand vous dites c'est très dur
alors il ya une étude qui est menée par
le professeur fontanet que vous
connaissait il a été plusieurs fois et
plusieurs fois il intervenu en
conférence de presse qui a démarré une
étude pour rechercher avec des questions
très fine les lieux de contamination les
conditions de contamination de quelques
1500 français sur tout le territoire
national
ça va nous apprendre des enseignements
mais je peux vous dire si c'était votre
question à chaque fois qu'on peut
remonter au delà de la chaîne de
contamination nous le faisons et les
équipes des agences régionales de santé
les médecins les infirmières l'assurance
maladie à chaque fois qu'ils peuvent
essayer d'aller plus loin pour essayer
de comprendre s'il y avait un foyer de
contamination
évidemment ils y vont mais ne croyez pas
que ce soit quelque chose où il suffit
de claquer les doigts ou d'y mettre les
moyens
les réponses que nous n'arrivons pas à
avoir mais que personne dans le monde
n'arrive à obtenir peut-être répondre
sur les les projections en termes de pic
épidémique
là encore nous avons ce qu'on appelle
des modélisations la modélisation c'est
la capacité à anticiper on vous a
présenté en conférence de presse vous
souvenez des courbe ascensionnelle de de
remplissage des réanimations et des
hôpitaux et on permet et ses modèles
sont adaptées au fur et à mesure que de
nouvelles mesures sont prises et je vous
ai dit la dernière fois ce que nous
voulons c'est faire mentir ses courbes
donc il est sur cette base là difficile
de vous dire quand aura lieu le pic
finalement le pic il aura lieu ce sera
le moment où on aura enregistré l'
inflexion de la courbe d'incidence et on
commencera à réduire le nombre de cas
moi j'y vous voulez ma réponse ma
réponse idéale je serai la semaine
prochaine ça voudrait dire que les
mesures auraient permis d'infléchir la
courbe je n'en suis pas certain en tout
cas pas dans les proportions nécessaire
pour avoir vraiment une
une diminution franche que nous voulons
c'est déjà des premiers frémissements
d'une réduction de l'incidence au cours
de la semaine prochaine quant aux
prédictions à noël c'est comme h fait la
même réponse qu'à chaque fois quand on
parle de prédiction tout ce qui en fait
sont plantés donc nous faisons le
maximum sans regarder même la question
de noël pour protéger les français dans
la période actuelle dans lés semaines
venir évidemment dans les mois à venir
et donc plus nous agissons plus nous
sommes solidaires plus vous intervenants
contre ce virus
plus nous faisons attention dans nos
comportements quotidiens plus nous avons
de chances de pouvoir passer noël en
famille dans les meilleures conditions
merci monsieur le ministre en tout cas
notre responsabilités la mienne en
particulier c'est évidemment d'abord de
prendre les bonnes mesures de veiller à
leur application et d'anticiper toutes
les hypothèses les bonnes bien sûr c'est
celle que nous cherchons à réaliser mais
aussi les plus difficiles
sinon nous faille irions à notre rôle il
y avait une question pour tous en tic au
vide sur le secrétaire d'état oui
monsieur le premier premier ministre
s'agissant de la communication sur
l'application tout senti qu vide
d'abord à partir d'aujourd'hui
l'ensemble des communications du
gouvernement sur les gestes barrières
intégreront tout senti que vide et donc
dans toutes les communications général
du gouvernement tout senti que vide sera
recommandée à télécharger c'est le
premier et le deuxième élément nous
travaillons à des campagnes spécifiques
surtout anti covin notre âme notamment
sur les réseaux sociaux qui sont en
train d'être travaillée par notamment le
service d'information du gouvernement et
ministère de la santé pour mettre en
avant particulièrement le soutien quasi
unanime je pense de la communauté
médicale mais aussi du secteur de la
restauration du secteur du théâtre
vivant du secteur du cinéma pour pousser
et inciter tous les français à
télécharger ou à activer cette
application quand il arrive dans un
établissement recevant du public et nous
travaillons particulièrement avec
l'ensemble de ses secteurs
je disais les restaurants les bars les
cinémas les salles de spectacles pour
faire en sorte qu'à chaque fois que vous
entrez dans un restaurant ou dans un de
ces lieux il y ait un qr code ou un
rappel qui vous rappelle que c'est
extrêmement utile d'avoir tout senti que
vides pour éviter d'avoir des chaînes de
compilation qu'on ne connaît pas et pour
garder ces lieux ouverts nous
travaillons par ailleurs j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire
à en faire un outil quotidien pour faire
en sorte que cela devienne un réflexe et
je le dis encore une fois ici j'appelle
tous les restaurateurs tous les
tenanciers de bars les propriétaires de
salles de spectacles les entreprises qui
assurent des cantines collectives à nous
aider à rappeler incessamment l'utilité
de cette application
c'est quelque chose que nous aurons
besoin de faire dans la durée
nous voulons faire en sorte que nous en
parlions et que tout le monde en parle
partout tout le temps merci beaucoup
cédric alors quelques questions
supplémentaires si vous le souhaitez
dans prix madame je viens la liste pour
bfm tv
vous évoquez notamment les vacances de
noël là en ce moment on est en vacances
de la toussaint
au vu de ce qui se passe et la situation
qui se dégrade par rapport au port du
masque est ce que vous conseiller en
tout cas ce que vous demander
solennellement ou pas aux français de
porter le masque le plus possible dans
la sphère privée
bonjour j'ai à me marot de la fp la
situation sanitaire actuelle montrent
que les différents messages d alerte
vous les avez lancé depuis la rentrée à
destination des plus jeunes n'ont pas
vraiment imprimé au vu des taux
d'incidence est ce que vous réfléchissez
à ce que vous dressez sait déjà ce
constat d'échec est ce que vous
réfléchissez à revoir votre
communication à chercher des relais
alternatif pour pouvoir s'adresser à
cette population qui visiblement pas du
tout à ces petits verres aux
avertissements bonjour nicollin pour tf1
lci vous parlez souvent d'anticipation
pourquoi ne pas envisager dès maintenant
si la situation est si grave un couvre
feu sur l'ensemble du territoire
français
bonjour aux mains cruelles pour rmc
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
les raisons de ce changement de
stratégie jusqu'ici le couvre-feu était
principalement sur des métropoles dont
il y avait la région ile de france
pourquoi passer sur des départements et
je rejoins mon collègue pourquoi ne pas
l'étendre à tous les départements
français vous disait que certains
départements étaient placés en couvre
feu par précaution alors là on va se
toutes ces questions sont cohérentes
entre elles donc on va pouvoir y
répondre
j'invite le misa santé à venir parce que
les réponses sont me semble-t-il
extrêmement claire simplement pour pour
bfm tv le port du masque le plus
possible partout je ne cesse de le dire
donc raison plus maintenant voilà le
vous souvenez que j'avais dit que le
virus ne prenait pas de vacances cet été
il n'en prend pas davantage pendant ces
vacances de toussaint
donc il faut rester vigilant et le port
du masque est l'une des manifestations
de cette vigilance
monsieur le ministre est-ce qu'on a été
bons dans la communication à destination
des jeunes c'est difficile de répondre à
cette question
c'est difficile de répondre à cette
question je me permets quel rôle le
avons une avons nous vu les uns les
autres dans la période de reprise
épidémie qui sévit des jeunes dans les
messages que nous véhiculons
il m'arrive de trouver le temps
d'allumer des chaînes de télévision il
nous revient absolument pas de faire
quelques 100 sûr que ce soit et je ne
parle pas de votre chaîne en
l'occurrence enfin on continue
d'entendre sur certains plateaux de
télévision des gens qui se disent expert
en dépit des théologies ou en virologie
qui ne sont pas et qui continue proférer
les choses qui sont totalement fausses
si vous me posez la question pour avoir
bataillé un peu comme don quichotte
pendant la période de jeu vous fait rire
parce que vous savez que c'est vrai pour
la période du mois d'août
et la rentrée de septembre pour
expliquer que non non pas parce que vous
êtes jeunes que vous risquez rien c'est
pas parce que les malades sont plus
jeunes c'est parce que les malades les
plus fréquents sont les plus jeunes qui
n'avaient pas encore un impact sanitaire
mais que oui les personnes fragiles
avaient tôt ou tard être atteinte et que
non le virus n'avait pas muté pour être
moins dangereux je peux vous dire que
oui peut-être qu'il faut trouver
d'autres vecteurs d'autres supports de
communication m'enfin on n'a pas
toujours été complètement aider mais ça
veut pas dire que on se dédouane de
notre responsabilité je me dédouane de
la vienne s'agissant des messages qui
ont pu être envoyés et permettez moi
pardon le ministre de de féliciter
beaucoup d'initiatives qui sont prises à
destination de ce public compris par des
associations étudiantes et universitaire
partout existe beaucoup de collectivités
locales dès cet été d'ailleurs qui ont
pris des service civique des jeunes qui
sont allés porter le message auprès de
de tous les gens de leur génération donc
des initiatives ont été prises
elle s'amplifie effectivement les
messages on va dire plus
institutionnelle en quelques difficultés
à atteindre cette cible
mais vingt mais je fais confiance je
dirige gardons-nous là encore de
généraliser sur la question du
couvre-feu pourquoi est ce qu'il n'est
pas national ben écoutez le principe de
différenciation territoriales c'est un
principe qui était plébiscité est
d'ailleurs beaucoup de questions qui ont
été posées les semaines précédentes
portaient sur le fait de savoir si on
allait effectivement bien continuer à
tenir compte de la réalité épidémiques
sont un territoire ou un autre je
parlais de saint-etienne pas pour
stigmatiser saint-etienne je fais
attention mais saint-etienne à
l'incidence la plus élevée en termes de
métropole 800 cas pour 100000 habitants
vous comparer ça avec les territoire de
belfort où l'incidence est à 38 vous
avez donc un écart de 1 à 20 allait
appliquer les mêmes mesures sur ces deux
territoires au stade où nous en sommes
en tous les cas ne fait pas forcément
sens et donc la différenciation
territoriales permet de répondre à cela
mais les mesures qui ne sont pas
différencier les gestes barrière le
lavage des mains la distance le faire
attention chez soi faire attention tout
le temps finalement la limitation des
grands rassemblements
fermeture de certains établissements
recevant du public toutes ces règles
sont nationales mais ensuite on les
gradués on est gradué en fonction de la
réalité épidémique est pourquoi à
l'échelle départementale
parce que lorsque les premières mesures
de couvre-feu ont été appliquées dans
les zones d'alerté maximale qui ciblait
les métropoles et bien rapidement compte
tenu de l'évolution d'épidémie des
communes qui pouvait être à 20 à 30 km
et qui présentaient des statistiques des
en termes d'incidence et de et de cas
graves
quasiment identiques aux grandes
métropoles n'étaient pas soumises aux
mêmes règles ce qui n'était absolument
pas cohérent donc on crée de la
cohérence territoriale et je termine en
vous disant sur ce sujet très important
parce qu'il faut et vous avez raison de
nous poser la question expliquer et
expliquer sans cesse le couvre feu
comme d'autres mesures que nous avons
prises sont des mesures difficiles
lourde qui portent atteinte à notre
liberté d'aller et venir nous sommes
dans un état de droit et c'est heureux
quand on prend quand les gouvernements
prennent des mesures de cette nature il
faut qu'elles puissent en apporter la
justification
les justifications on a été tout à fait
transparent des mesures de couvre-feu
repose sur des indicateurs sanitaires
les taux d'incidence de la population
générale des personnes âgées de plus de
65 ans le taux d'admission actuelle est
projeté dans les services de réanimation
et c'est lorsque ces seuils sont
déclenchés que nous prenons les mesures
je vous ai dit aujourd'hui vous l'avez
parfaitement relevé que j'ai un peu
anticipé pour une certaine catégorie de
département parce qu'ils sont pas très
loin mais pour autant le ministre a
donné la distribution il faut qu'on
puisse être cohérent et justifiées y
compris le cas échéant devant un juge
que nous prenons des mesures de cette
nature donc je pense que nous anticipons
nous avons incontestablement compte tenu
de la gravité de la situation
pris des dispositions fortes pour
important à la fois pour être justifiée
pour être acceptée il faut que ces
mesures soit proportionnée et adaptée
aux réalités je vous remercie vivement
et je vous dis à très bientôt